brandon says what age difference is too
much
i'm in my early 30s a girl in her early
20s
is in my bible study and she has a
boyfriend can't get her out of my head
i'm trying to work on myself the
question is more about age difference
so i'm going to set aside that you're
that you've got one itis for a check
that you should
that you've never been with and i'm just
going to deal with the age difference
thing
so early 30s so let's call it 33 and
she's in her early 20s so let's call her
23 so she's probably at her peak there's
a 10-year difference
that's that's not a problem at all i
would tell guys
to go generally speaking for
the optimal experience seven to ten
years younger seven to ten years younger
is fine you can go more than that but 70
10 years younger is totally fine
you're going to run into problems if
you're a 50 year old and she's 25
trying to relate on a lot of stuff you
know
music movies culture all that sort of
stuff there's gonna be differences there
so you just have to understand that they
do exist
um but a seven to ten year difference is
no big deal you shouldn't even bat an
eye at it it should be like no problem
at all
if that makes sense revolting one says
if you're a 47 year old it can easily
pick up 18 years old after being red
pill
is this considered too pervy no i mean
if she's
if you are going to be told yes but i'm
going to tell you no if if she's over
the age of majority like if she's an
adult
in your country territory private state
wherever you live
it's not it's it's fine um i think that
the
definition of um what is it pedophile
um i think if you look it up it it's
generally
defined as when you're attracted to
the opposite sex and they haven't hit
puberty yet so you're talking about age
of majority i mean
you could be 60 and she could be 18.
yeah it's gonna look weird and dorky but
if you can pull it off go for it i'm
glad that you're asking for a friend
always ask for friends
you